c'est le moment il est temps pour nous
d'écouter lavoir de la révolte la voix
de l'état français représenté par le
procureur général de la république des
proches française
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président chers coco la
syncope
mesdames et messieurs les jurés public
chéri mon amour a fist renom il n'est
point sow le vieux dicton populaire qui
dit que ce sont toujours les meilleurs
qui partent les premiers
la preuve bill haley est mort et cerrone
est toujours vivant
[Applaudissements]
un chiffre en cure heures ironie triste
ironie j'ai lu sous la plume d'un
journal du matin à vide de lieux communs
que je cite bilal s est éteint sans
bruit n'est ce pas le comble de la
misère pour un homme qui réveillait en
son temps l'amérique somnolence
d'eisenhower à coups de décibels mais ce
poêle comble pour le père de rock around
the clock que de s'éteindre sans bruit à
ce n'est pas vous si ron qui vous êtes
andrier sans bruit vous le défenseur de
tympans systématique vous le pape du
marteau pilon le nabab du boum boum
obsessionnel l'ayatollah fanatiques des
boutonneux névrosé
soyons justes mesdames et messieurs les
jurés puisque finalement c'est un peu
notre métier d'être juste encore que
peyrefitte me disait hier soir à la fin
d'une orgie chez marie france il m'a dit
tu te casse pas la tête
coco juste ou injuste c'est payé pareil
à la fin du mois
coupons court voler vos coupons court
juste avant comme dit jacques
pierrefitte oui mais enfin soyons justes
donc l'accusé cerrone ici présent n'a
pas toujours été là jt disco maniaque
qui nous infligent aujourd'hui le
désolant spectacle d'une bête humaine
complètement ravagée par l'abus de
l'alcool et les excès destructeur de
l'électronique musicale catégorie
sous-doués tout petit c'est ron était un
enfant normal presque normale bien sûr
on ne se refait pas il avait déjà cette
tête là mais comme il était tout petit
elle était moins grosses et donc on la
voyait moins bien sauf de très près
c'est une simple question d'optique
mesdames et messieurs les jurés mais je
ne m'étendrai pas plus sur ce sujet on
n'est pas là pour faire de la pub au
frère gay lussac cerrone était donc un
petit garçon normal horrible certes mais
normal ils mangeraient normalement c'est
bouillie il arrachait normalement les
ailes des mouches et il s'enfonçait
normalement des noyaux de pêche dans le
nez comme tous les enfants du monde
tous les enfants du monde sauf la petite
ella fitzgerald qui s'enfonçait des
noyaux d'avocats dans le nez
c'est pas pour vous mais gauche c'est
pas par eux non effectivement j'aimerais
bien que m e rigaud cesse de regarder
ainsi quand je parle de noyaux d'avocats
dans le nez jelavic général ne voyez là
aucune allusion à votre vie privée et
cher m d'ailleurs vous avez parfaitement
le droit de vous livrer à des
expériences rhinopharyngées à la
nouvelle orléans sans que quiconque y
trouve à redire donc donc si ron était
un petit garçon horrible mais normal
encore que encore que son âpreté au gain
son amour insensé de l'argent son sens
incroyable de l'économie se sont révélés
très très tôt le jour même de sa
naissance à vrai dire on su que ça
allait être un enfant radin à ce stade
de mon discours mesdames et messieurs
les jurés mon réquisitoire va ressembler
un cours d'obstétrique et je m'en excuse
par avance auprès du professeur albert
poussé madame je ne voudrais pas lui
ôter le place est le je ne voudrais pas
lui ôter le pain de la gauche en
empiétant sur ses plates-bandes pendant
qu'il est chez guy lux puisqu'il est
vice président de l'ordre des médecins
qui font de la télé pendant les heures
de consultation un ordre et plus en plus
répandue au moment de la naissance
l'enfant normalement se présente par la
tête ou par le siège
le ciel ça veut dire le cube et les
médecins ne parle pas comme tout le
monde
sinon tout le monde comprendrait ce
qu'ils disent ça ferait tomber diafoirus
de son piédestal j'en frémis rien que
d'y penser qu'elles peuvent fois
l'enfant se présente mal par le genou
par exemple quelquefois aussi l'enfant
ne se présente pas correctement ce qu'il
est très mal élevé que dans ce cas là
comme on le chante sous les pergolas
actuellement le mieux est de pratiquer l
interruption volontaire de grossesse
si possible entre le huitième mois et
l'entrée en 6ème parce qu'après on
s'attache
enfin si l'enfant ne se présente pas du
tout l'accoucheur devra appliquer le
principe di principe de sautet ou encore
principe de césar et rosalie c'est à
dire que si la coucher et un est un
homme en pratiquera une césarienne
si la couche est une femme on pratiquera
une rose aliens j'espère que les futurs
jeunes mamans elles futur jeune papa qui
m'écoutent prennent des notes ça leur
évitera de dire des conneries au moment
de mettre bas mais je m'écarte du sujet
enfin on va parler donc plus du forceps
parce qu'on s'en fout c'est pas ça
retournons à vérone pardon revenons à
pétrole à s'érode sillage ici le jour de
sa naissance virol ne sait pas dire si
rome ne s'est présenté ni par la tête ni
par le siège en fait il a failli se
présenter par le siège mais il était
déjà tellement radin qu'il s'est
présenté par le strapontin pour
économiser ainsi avant de digresser 1,6
disais donc que si ron était un enfant
normal jusqu'au jour où je le lis dans
le dossier d'instruction
en voyant son père cordonnier martelé le
cuir du matin au soir il fut pris d'un
besoin irrépressible de taper sur
quelque chose en cadence et c'est là
mesdames et messieurs les jurés que nous
apparaît clairement le danger qu'ils
représentent la famille pour l'éducation
des enfants
c'est pourquoi j'accorderai les
circonstances atténuantes à l'accusée
car enfin qui sait si le père de cerrone
avait été fabricant de ceinture
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui au lieu de nous
vrille et les portugaises avec ses
bruits de gamelles pour handicapés
mentaux
il l'a bouclerait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
etonnant non